I want to pull out this sweet guys we  need this everyone everyone we're going  to go through these exercises  the New York Times says elections and  anxiety often go hand in hand here are  some evidence-based strategies that can  help you cope  with what  try five finger breathing trace the  outside of your hand with your pointer  finger when you trace up breathe in and  when you trace down breathe out  oh  breathing like that just makes you I'm  just angry like because everybody's like  somebody's like here's your breath I'm  like here's what we're gonna see it's  gonna be that woman screaming no again  but she's gonna drop 20s ago  they're gonna change the the Tommy fists  to the the finger pointing here we go  cool down listen no no guys guys plunge  your face into a bowl with ice water for  15 to 30 seconds yo what is  it sounds fun